hey everyone it's Micha alos and this is
the orderflows market analysis for
Friday July 28th 2017 so the Dow ended
up with a fractional gain I think a very
small gain um but it more importantly
ended the week up about
1.2% uh crude oil ended up uh near
$50 it had a very strong gain on the
week as uh basically Saudi is talking
about output
cuts and today on Friday you had the
second quarter GDP hit expectation at uh
2.6% consumer spending at 2.8% we're
seeing uh strengthened business
investment offsetting week showing for
housing so you know all that means is uh
it means inflation is low posting only
about a 1% Pace in the quarter and
Trends are pointing to the 2% full year
GDP Target that the fomc expects to see
this year so you know everything is uh
going smoothly thanks Donald Trump no
just kidding but um brief uh before we
jump in looking at the charts brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without shepardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results so the
tools I use in this presentation as
usual are the order flows Trader and the
Delta scalper overflows Trader is the
volume footprint chart that you see um
you know in pretty much all my slides
and you occasionally I do show bar
charts you know for EAS of ease of uh
explanation on on an indicator like the
Delta scalper but uh you know the volume
footprint chart is is a great chart
you'll be able to see what's really
going on inside the bar you know the
struggle between the buyers and the
sellers so uh let's take a look at a
chart first chart up that I want talk
about is the uh e- mini it's the 10
range
chart and it's disappeared on
me hang
on okay so uh here it is the this is the
e- mini smpp that this is the 10 range
chart and you know every day I talk
about ratios and Divergence you know a
Divergence is when you have a new or
equal low and positive Delta right
you're in your low you should be
expecting to see a negative Delta and
that that's why you have a Divergence
now you know the ratio is is something a
little bit different it reads the order
flow and it's puts outputs these numbers
here like
c82 uh 272 some are black some are blue
now if it's blue that's a ratio that I
like okay it's telling me you know
there's something interesting in the
order flow either there's price
rejection or Price defense now you know
one of the trade setups that I I talk
about almost daily occurring I see it uh
every day and I talk about it you know
in these videos
is when you get a Divergence here this
has this green arrow telling you there's
a Divergence in the in the market right
now and then look for a blue number here
now when you have a Divergence if you
don't get the blue number in the bar
with the Divergence look to the next bar
okay if you have a ratio there I still
like it you know cuz sometimes for
whatever reason you may not be able to
get the the actual um you know ratio
that you like you know at your low or at
your
high but you know again you know ratios
are signs of price defense or Price
rejection so you know if I have a
Divergence okay to me that's already a
sign that the market could be changing
so what I want to look for is signs in
the order flow of price defense meaning
you know this low is being defended with
heavy volume or Price rejection meaning
lesser volume in the order flow that
prices down here are being rejected so
you don't get a ratio here but you do
have the Divergence in the next bar
you've got the uh ratio balance High
there's two types of ratios ratio bonds
low ratio bonds High one indicates price
defense one indicates price rejection
but I treat them the same whether it's
ratio bonds low ratio bonds High really
what I'm looking for is the blue number
to tell me that there's either you know
ratio bonds low or ratio bonds
high and you know we're starting to move
up you know we got the Divergence and
then I see a sign here of price
rejection down here at these lows and
you know the market pops up you know it
makes a nice little move from 66 all the
way up to 69 um then you come up here
you see a bearish ratio you got price
rejection up here Delta scalper kicking
in just after the swing high and you
sell off you sell off down to new lows
10: a.m. you get a another
Divergence no ratio it's just a black
number then you get the diver then you
get the ratio in the next bar which is
again indicating price rejection this is
a ratio bounce
high and then the market just continues
its rally um again you know from that
same area 2466 all the way up to where
we closed at around 2471 so you know
there was actually three nice trades
here there was the first ratio and
Divergence which was good for a couple
of
points Delta Scupper is also good for
you know something I don't know what you
would have got out of this you know it
just sort of went sideways before it
gave another buy here and at 66 you know
all the way up to 70 so you know there
was points to be had and you know that's
why I talk about points in the snps
rather than ticks right A lot of people
are trading with you know they're just
looking for the next couple of ticks
would you rather be trading for ticks or
for points you know I I think it's
better to trade for points rather than
ticks all right so the next market I'll
talk about is are the five years and
again same thing obvious we talk about
ratio and Divergence either you know
ratio and Divergence on the bar or ratio
and Divergence uh Divergence and ratio
on the next bar so and how how to manage
the trade okay so here you got a ratio
5.7 sorry. 57 and Divergence and it
fails why does it fail you've got a very
be you got a bearish ratio immediately
after you got your bullish ratio now you
know it's
about the thing that about order flow
that that you know is is useful is you
could be reading what the market is
telling you right and you know so you're
taking a trade you got a bullish sign
here but then you're get a bearish sign
right afterwards you know don't stay in
the trade you know get out there there's
nobody gotta has a gun to your head
saying you got to stay in this trade
because you bought because you got to
Divergence and a ratio if the market is
telling you it comes right back with um
a bearish ratio and you got multiple
imbalances in the bar it's not a good
sign that this trade is going to be
working out really what you want is is
the green bar afterwards you want buying
in balances not selling in balances not
a bearish ratio and you see how the
market makes a new low now later you get
this you get a high up here granted at
736 just after number that's fine this
Market is kind of quieted down for now
Divergence no ratio ratio in the next
bar you also have Delta scalper kicking
off there as well and you know the
market circles back up to the high of
this bar one take higher a bearish ratio
as well and the market makes a nice move
so you know this first trade that this
morning you know is is a loser you know
but you could cut your loss here you
don't have to go let the market come to
your you know stop you out you could get
out here there's plenty of volume to get
out before it breaks lower then you got
a nice trade here you know everything is
confirming there's no reason to be
getting out of this trade as it pulls
back up here you know your stop is up
here at you know around the high and it
makes a nice move down you know from one
from 04 down to um double O then rallies
back
up boom boom boom the ratio and
Divergence this one fails but it comes
back again you know like I say you know
watch what's happening you got a bullish
ratio right you don't have a red bar you
don't have a bearish ratio you don't
have anything following up on it that's
how you know to cut your loss here
rather than let it stop you out up here
and then again later you got the
Divergence and the ratio
afterwards um Market really slowed down
after after 11: a.m. um you just sort of
went sideways on you before closing you
know here at 4 and a quarter
so you know that's how you trade right
you read what's the Market's telling you
and you react to it you don't trade
based on oh I got a Buy Signal here I
just got to buy and let the market go to
my
uh either my profit Target or stop me
out no you know if you're reading
something in the order flow that's that
is telling you hey you know it's changed
you know here even though you have this
bearish sign here over the next several
minutes you know conditions changed in
the market you know that that's the
that's the thing that you know a lot of
these quote trading indicators out there
lack is you know they they don't tell
you that hey the trade's not working out
you know you're just supposed to take
the trade and let it go you know but if
you're reading the order flow you can
understand what's happening in the
market and react accordingly you know
get out early rather than let it stop
you
out okay so uh next Market talk about is
uh the euro currency now again this is
sort of goes back to the I I should
create a special section on my website
preaching to the choir um again it's the
same things again it's not rocket
scientist or rocket science rocket
scientists it's not rocket
science you know I try to make orderflow
as simple as possible for people
and again you know whether people want
to use the tools that we develop or or
not it's up to them but again you know I
maybe I sound like I'm I'm drinking the
Kool-Aid or whatnot but you know again
these are the things that you know occur
every day in the order flow and if you
don't know how to look at it or even
want to look at it you're just basically
leaving money on the table now again
this is this is a you know if you just
read the Delta okay forget indicators
forget ratios forget all that stuff okay
maybe you don't believe in that fine
read the order flow read the Deltas you
know as you're going up here right watch
when you get up to the highs what's
happening at highs is is what you want
to know right if we get up to a high are
we going to sell off or not you know
what's going to happen are we going to
continue to go higher go sideways you
know you want to be taking trades that
make sense okay um you know a lot of
people again you know a lot of people
trade with indicators they don't give a
about what's actually happening in
the market you know it's oh this
indicator says sell so I'm going to sell
but you know read what's happening in
the market now so here I give you a
quick lesson Delta make a new high
strong positive Delta 273 yes that's
what you want got a new high got weaker
Delta that's not good you're on your
high you got a weak Delta very weak 19
I'll say very weak but it's kind of a
neutral right there's sort of a range I
consider Delta to be neutral in um
meaning it could go either way very
easily and 19 you know generally it's
less than 50 but you know in contracts
like euro currency or contract I trade
less volume um it's probably lesser it's
probably around 25 but you know so 19
very easily it could be difference of
one trade okay maybe if there's just a
little bit more volume here someone was
bidding an extra 20 Lots here boom you'd
have a negative Delta but it it wasn't
so to me it really sort of falls into
this range I mean but still nevertheless
it's still positive okay you're at your
high you got a small Delta 19 so you got
273 981 19 what's happening you're going
higher yes but your Delta is getting
weaker so it's telling you net
aggressive buyers are
declining then watch for the bar after
the high boom negative Delta so you got
weaker negative Delta coming up to the
high sorry weaker positive Delta coming
up into the high you make your turn you
start trading lower the bar closes lower
than where it opened on your high next
bar got negative Delta so you went from
strong buying as you're breaking out the
new highs to weaker buying as you're
going a little bit higher on your high
you've got very weak buying buying very
weak aggressive buying then you're
starting to come down you've got selling
taking over okay that's again that's a
sign that hey you know what we're
shifting okay sellers are coming in next
bar what happens a stronger negative
Delta so more sellers are active now
that's your sign to be getting short you
know Delta scalper is picking it up
right here that's this this uh fuchsia
color thing Zone um okay so you know
you've got a perfect reason just based
it you know on the order flow here Order
flow of the Delta to be getting short
okay and where are you trading right now
you're trading
11738 okay what happens the market sells
off it comes all the way down to you
know down to what is that 22 but you
know it sort of bases out in here um
around the 25 26 area so you know it's a
decent move from 38 down to
26 yeah that's over 20 ticks in the uh
trades in half ticks that's a decent
move there
and that's just by reading the order
flow simple simple stuff um okay so now
you know let's just talk about some
other things you get this high up here
you got trap Traders that's this red
arrow you got a bearish ratio as
well and what happens is you know that's
why you know these tools I don't like to
call them indicators I prefer to call
them tools you know this red arrow is a
tool that tells me there's trap Traders
up here based on the order flow it's not
an indicator I still like to look at
what's happening in the market and
you got people trapped up here at the
High people are long and wrong and they
got to get out you know and you see how
the market sells off like that you know
people always talk about what trapped
Traders are but you have to when you
have trapped Traders you got to look at
what happens after Traders are trapped
right when Traders are trapped up here
generally the Market's going to come off
that's when people talk about trap
Traders they're stuck they got to get
out and there was something else okay uh
you got high you had a Divergence but no
ratio no ratio in the next bar granted
it's at
7:30 um new highs after the
number got a again this is 731 even
though it is a Divergence in a ratio
afterwards again I'm not going to be
trading when the GDP comes out um this
is at 7:31 in the morning can it came
out a minute earlier Market did sell off
off this you know I mean I could I could
sit here and say yeah see I told you
ratio on Divergence but you know I got
to be realistic I don't trade during the
numbers okay and honestly I think it'd
be a fool to trade during the numbers
unless you know you got unless you hear
privy to what the numbers come out at um
but anyway you know Market uh Market had
a nice selloff nice sell off you getting
some you know Delta scalper sell here
before it turns around and you know I
wanted to talk about this there was a
high here somewhere if I can dig it
out around 10 or
so yeah here we are so we're coming up
into this high
you got a new high you got a uh
Divergence and you got a ratio zero
print and what happens again ratio and
Divergence ratio and Divergence you hear
me talk about that you know almost on
every chart U why because it works okay
and boom you get a nice sell off here
from 89 down to 79 really quick so again
you know I I talk about these things
ratio and Divergence you're probably
sick of me thinking oh you put them in a
straight jacket he's you know
keeps saying ratio Divergence raal di
but it works you know it it works all
right so uh I'll talk about crude oil
now you know
crude Black
Gold exist so you know in the morning
you got Delta scalper buy Delta scalper
sell you know get some little moves here
it's 4 in the morning okay so we start
making new highs got some failed
divergences Delta Scupper didn't work
out there um you get up to this High
here
930 you Delta scalper and Delta scalper
right
afterwards and I mean again I'm not
going to say oh you got Delta scaler
Delta scer afterwards you know it's it's
uh more powerful but you know I like
when you get Delta scer cells near highs
or Delta scalper buys near lows you know
you had one here that didn't work out
okay fine you know it's not the end of
the world look for your next trade you
know then you get you get a trade here
you get a nice little move down not not
the greatest uh not the greatest trade
but you know what you at least you're
getting a profit right I mean you know
we all like the moves that go from their
High to your low but sometimes times you
know that that just doesn't
happen you know that's why I always say
you know take you can only take what the
Market's giving you so if it's only
giving you you know 15 20 ticks then you
know take it and be happy and look for
your next trade okay so lastly I I'll
talk about this uh Delta scalper really
quick is a eurocurrency 5 minute bar um
I'm going to do a separate presentation
on the Delta scalper but you know just
give you an idea of you know how it
looked this
morning you know 10 o'clock last night
you get in a sell you get a little bit
of a move not much you know I mean it's
it's Asian session Friday you're not
getting much here you get a little sell
here this one nothing this one you get a
nice move
up you know from what is that I don't
know 27 28 up to you know 40 something
um get a little sell here then you get
another buy right here this was a nicer
buy here around six and morning again
I'm not going to say hold the position
through the number right after the
number you get a
sell um this sell didn't work
out then you got another sell up here um
I don't know what time that is
10:45 you know that's not not a great
move but you know it's it's I said you
know there were some nice moves some
lousy I'll say some not lousy moves but
you get some nice big moves and some
smaller moves you know it's just a
function of what the Market's doing
um on that day you know sometimes you're
going to get big moves sometimes you're
going to get smaller
moves okay quickly again you again I'm
going to do a separate presentation on
the Delta scalper charts but uh you know
really quick NASDAQ again you know this
is at just before midnight you had a
little buy there nothing nothing special
um all the activity happened during the
day session yeah here 8 in the morning
after 8 you're getting a couple buys
don't really work out this one first one
no second one uh not really um cash
opens you a little sell here didn't
really work out then um you make your
run up to 5905 Delta scalper gave a
couple sells right up
here and you know these were this was a
nice trade um this sell didn't work out
this buy
okay this buy nice little buy
here this one no this one failed here
the second one again it shot up before
broke down but again you know trailing
your stop and here you get a nice sell
um this area this was a difficult area
here this one I you I don't like that it
poked through here but you know before
you know it poked through rallied up
came back down to these levels and made
a nice rally you know that one I I think
most people would be stopped out on um
you know then later in the day not much
just you know I say a bit of a struggle
but you're getting little popups you
know a couple bars in the right
direction at at a minimum but but anyway
you know I'm going to do a second
presentation on the uh Delta scalper uh
after I finish this one okay so thanks
for watching this to learn more about
the trading software orderflows go to uh
order flows.com to learn more about the
orderflows trader and uh Deltas
scaler.com to learn more about the
Deltas scalper so thanks everyone
bye-bye